SPEAKER: What's up, everyone?
Thanks for checking
out this week
in Cloud, where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
Ever wish you could get
a little more oomph out
of your virtual machines?
Google's happy to now offer
an expanded range of compute
and memory optimized machines.
These let you optimize
your virtual machines
for workloads that might
need that extra power.
You can get signed up for early
access now, so get moving.
This week, we're excited to
announce Elastifile for GCP.
With Elastifile, we've
reinvented file storage
as a fully managed service.
This means you get
to take advantage
of all the benefits of a
traditional file storage
system, such as high
availability and easy sharing,
without the hassle
of forecasting,
managing, and provisioning
enterprise storage
all by yourself.
Features like petabyte
capacity and auto scaling
make high-performance
compute jobs easier than ever
while built-in controls
allow you to optimize
for price or performance.
Find out how you can
improve your workflow
with Elastifile for GCP.
Last year, we announced
Cloud Memorystore
for Redis, our fully managed
in-memory datastore service.
And because users responded
by adopting so quickly,
this year, we're excited to
announce Cloud Memorystore
support for Redis version
4.0, available in beta as well
as a new manual failover API.
Learn how to access
the new version
and tour smart new features
like cached improvement
and active memory
defragmentation.
You're already running
infrastructure as code, right?
No?
What if you need to
quickly replicate VMs
between environments,
or track changes,
or scale your configuration by
the thousands for production?
The good news is
that with GCP, you
can use Deployment Manager
or the ever-popular Terraform
without any additional setup.
You'll be able to make
changes to your environment
in a way that can be tested,
audited, and automatically
applied, according to your
change management processes,
allowing your app to
scale effortlessly
with massive
increases in demand.
Read everything you
need to know to get
started running infrastructure
as code today on the GCP blog.
The secret's out.
We're making our BigQuery
migration bundle offer
generally available to everyone.
That means in
addition to BigQuery,
you'll get proof of
concept funding support,
expert advice on
architecture design,
and online courses
at no extra cost.
Find out why an independent
analysis firm concluded
that enterprise
customers could save up
to 52% on total cost of
ownership over three years
by switching to the Cloud.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.